Okay,
so you see you don't see irrelevant
things.
That's most things you do.
See things that move you forward and you
do see things that get in your way and
in the class of things that get in your
way are in determinant occurrences,
novel or anomalous occurrences,
and almost everything that gets in your
way is in some sense a novel occurrence
because you usually structure your
behavior so that you don't go anywhere
where something wildly anomalous is
likely to occur,
so,
so not if you encountered an obstacle to
things happening at the same time and
one is that your movement forward to
your specific goal or sets of goals is
blocked,
but the second thing that happens is
you're faced with a mystery and the
mystery is this thing wasn't supposed to
exist,
but it does exist.
So what implication does that have for
everything?
I think,
and that's very,
very hard on people.
They do not like that at all and no
wonder because it's,
it's,
it's the constrained chaos that's
underneath everything inhibited by your
contextual knowledge that suddenly
popped its head up into your world.
It's like it's like the shark in the
movie jaws,
which is of course a mythological story.
It's exactly that and,
and it's,
it's exactly what that movie signified,
a safe vacation paradise all of a sudden
threatened by some subterranean thing
that can pull you down and and that
destroys the peace and the harmony of
that particular community to dragon
story.
It's a hero myth.
It's,
it's the story that people have been
telling forever,
so,
so what you can think,
you can think of that thing that
re-emerges,
that shark that rises up from the depths
or that whale or that dragon or that
Predator or or the foreign invader for
that matter or the barbarian,
and they all fit into the same category.
That's what had been deemed irrelevant
suddenly manifesting itself.
And when you think about how much is
deemed irrelevant,
the fact that it's suddenly manifests
itself,
that's exactly the purpose for the
reason for the,
for the trauma.
It's like,
well,
I've,
I've eradicated from my
conceptualizations,
99 point nine,
nine percent of everything.
It's zeroed out and all of a sudden I've
made a mistake,
bang.
I don't know where I am.
Well,
what's relevant when you don't know
where you are and the answer to that is,
since you don't know everything is
relevant and you can imagine the sort of
terror that people who experienced
paranoid schizophrenia are living in
perennially because what happens to them
is precisely that they undergo
neurophysiological transformations that
makes everything that they once depended
on disappear and everything comes back
is relevant and that puts them in the
early stages of schizophrenia.
That's extraordinarily stressful
neurophysiologically,
so they're overwhelmed with cortisol and
their brains don't deteriorate as a
consequence of that is just too much,
so unsurprisingly,
right?
Because you can't deal with.
You can deal with anything,
let alone with everything.
Now and often what you see,
and it's rarely conceptualized this way
in,
in the training of of of clinical
therapists,
but often what you see when you are
dealing with people who are in crisis
isn't people who have a mental illness.
In fact,
in my experience,
that's actually quite rare.
What's far more common is that the
person that you're talking to has become
overwhelmed by catastrophe so their life
has fallen apart in some way that makes
what they're doing actually impossible.
You know,
so maybe someone very close to them in
their family that they were depending on
has developed a very serious illness and
that's throwing their entire financial
state into utter chaos.
Or maybe they've developed a condition
that makes it impossible for them to
work or you know you can.
You can imagine the potential range of
catastrophes and they're coming to see
you because they're anxious and
depressed,
but the reason they're anxious and
depressed is because everything they
have ignored has popped its head back up
and is hell bent on their destruction.
And often you see people who are being
attacked by five or six of these
monsters out at the same time and it
isn't their mental illness that stops
them from being able to deal with it.
Although that,
you know,
whatever weaknesses you have are going
to interfere.
It's the fact that what they're facing
is no damn joke.
And if you were facing it,
you'd feel exactly the same way.
So then you're trying to come up with
practical solutions to these
tremendously complex problems.
And that's a very,
a very well,
it's extraordinarily difficult.
Generally speaking,
people often don't come to a therapist
until they've exhausted their entire
range of resources.
They cannot figure out what to do.
And so,
you know,
in a situation like that you can
administer antidepressants and maybe
that'll help the person increase their
stress resistance.
But as a,
uh,
and it may be that because they're
depressed and have been brought down
that they are in fact exaggerating the
danger of some of the smaller monsters
that are after them,
but making the person more stress
resilient doesn't give them,
for example,
a new job.
And it certainly doesn't bring back the
person they've been living with for two
years who has a degenerating
neurological disease or some form of
cancer.
Like these things are major.
You know,
I often see people who,
while they're in a relationship,
maybe they're rather isolated,
older,
older people.
One of the partners is dying in their
entire financial situation has become
catastrophic.
It's like that's not a mental illness
man,
I mean they may have got into that
situation because of one inadequacy or
another,
but you don't even want to push that too
far because that sort of thing can
happen to anyone and and will in fact
happen to most people in one form or
another at least at some point in their
lives.
So you want to be damned prepared for
that.
You want to be prepared for that because
it's bitter and harsh and anxiety
provoking and painful,
but if you're not ready that it's also
hell.
And often you can stop things from
becoming hell even though you can't stop
them from being bitter and painful and
anxiety provoking and all of that.
You can at least delimit the catastrophe
enough so that it doesn't permanently
bring you and the people around you down
and that's,
that's not so bad,
right?
That's a hell or at least it's a lot
better than the alternative.
So this is the problem.
You know,
things object things are obstacles.
Well,
how big is the obstacle?
It's the same.
It's the same question is how big is the
Predator that's lurking outside the door
of our cave?
It's exactly the same problem except
construct,
conceptualized abstractly and and I
would say exactly the same systems that
you're distant ancestors used to
conceptualize the lurking Predator are
the systems that are activated now when
you encounter the reemergence of all the
monsters that you've ignored,
it's the same neurological platform you
think,
well,
how could it be otherwise?
Because evolution is a conservative
process.
Everything about you is built on on
ancient foundations,
right?
Very little new.
Certainly very little radically new
comes into existence.
It's mostly tinkering with structures
that have been around forever.
Like your body plan,
for example.
That's unbelievably old.
I mean you share that with.
You share that with lizards,
roughly speaking,
so it's incredibly ancient.